qu'ils soient gauche voulait dire et
bien là il faut que la droite sur un nom
la politique ça m'intéresse pas trop
justement c'est vrai on en parlera tout
s'avère d'ailleurs avec as c'est vrai
avec quelqu'un qui va venir nous voir
mais c'est vrai que vous n'avez pas on
peut voir une grande conscience
politique parce que je suis parle plutôt
du nutella et on n'en parle pas parce
que vous mettez là mais il ya quand même
quelque chose derrière arrêter les
conneries merde j'en ai parlé de 35 en
janvier quand je dis je je je ne suis
pas la politique parce qu'il m'intéresse
pas aux sais pas s'il va trop vite ça
mais j'ai jamais connue depuis que je
suis en âge de comprendre un homme
politique qui a tenu ses engagements
jusqu'au bout et qui m'a prouvé que ce
qu'ils disaient c'était vrai que il
pourrait changer les choses
vous en pensez-quoi que j'ai même quand
par exemple 100 millions et et contre le
vote des immigrés trouve ça regrettable
tout l'été comme quand il est pour la
peine de mort ou comme quand il est peu
contre l'avortement ou compte il est
pour le pacs comme ça dommage ce genre
de choses mais chacun sa vie en danger
mais la politique c'est le débat bien vu
puisque j'ai dit j'ai dit non j'ai juste
dit que impose à questionner pour que je
me sens capable mais je vais dans la
maison je crois qu'on peut on peut
débattre d'un certain nombre mais
véritablement où c'est pour je suis pas
pour la peine de mort je veux tu es
contre l'abolition de la peine de mort
parce qu'à l'époque il n'y avait pas de
peines de substitution
je dis qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le
problème est toujours posée parce qu
enfermer quelqu'un pour 18 ans pour 20
ans ou même au delà c'est l'enfermer
dans l'enfer et donc il faut que tu
restes non c'est pas du tout je savais
pas que ça soit il a galéré il fait un
spécial pour moi
alors que la dose qui porte sur pense
qu'il ya une réflexion à mener en
matière pénitentiaire pour savoir s'il
n'est pas meilleur de l'isoler dans un
cas quand vous vous dites fonctionner
dirais non j'ai pas du tout si vous avez
du talent a exigé des témoins sont deux
j'entendais marin mais paul blague à
part vous êtes pour la peine de mort je
ne suis pas pour la peine de mort je
suis pour une peine de substitution qui
soit applicable mais qu'ils soient
humaines
aujourd'hui la peine de substitution
comme ami elle est inhumaine
car enfermée qu'elle tient dans une
pièce de 4 mètres sur 4 durant 18 20 ans
22 ans 25 ans le tipi de viège
tout devient une loque d'accord et que
dans ce cas là il vaut peut-être mieux
chercher d'autres notes d'isolement
social c'est à dire on peut trouver il
existe et je vais vous dire un mot que
vous souhaitez puisque puisqu'on fait
une émission pêcheurs ainsi
touristiquement incorrect on va y aller
les méchants même le bagne le bagne est
meilleur que la prison à vie
car au moins vous êtes vous pouvez avoir
une activité et que on peut faire un
bagne moderne où les gens sont bannis
parce qu'on les met en dehors de la
société pour pas qu'ils ne portent
atteinte aux autres s'ils ne viennent
pas qu'il ne tue pas qu'ils n'atteignent
pas la liberté des autres
mais au moins on leur laisse une ère
d'expansion et de liberté et
d'épanouissement isoler la société que
je pense que le grand problème c'est que
voyez je vais l'utiliser un mot je suis
sûr que demain on va venir charles
millon un point le bagne j'ai pas dis
donc il ya des chances pour tous les cas
vous voyez la force des mots parce que
vous souvenez que quand edouard balladur
avait dit on devrait discuter de la
préférence nationale qui existe dans un
tas de pays dans le monde cf un scandale
bien là la force des mots tout à fait ce
soir vous saviez ça que la gauche et l
arbitre des élégances en france même
même alain madelin aujourd'hui dit qu'il
faut fumer des pétards non mais alain
madelin est un toxicomane famille aussi
non vous avez vous alliez au massacre
mais je pense que les choses changent
ouais parce que le blister avec la
boutique du pollen 10 00 c'est mort
hélas jamais vous avez jamais fumé de
peut-être jamais pu mais jamais jamais
été si jamais je venais de labeur de
l'air nous avons encore le temps s'ils
arrêtent tout est blanc quand on peut
tout en quoi est-ce que ça je suis sûr
vous avez fumé de la berre et pas
pourquoi vous avez une tête avant fumée
d'abord rang en conséquence même h au
soir